Nesladek:
Hi, I'm Chris Nesladek,
and I'm an interaction designer
working on the Android project.
Today I'm happy to be here
to present to you
"Pixel Perfect Code:
How to Marry Interaction and
Visual Design the Android Way."
Now, the goal of this talk,
which is a first of its kind
exploration--
so you guys
are the guinea pigs--
is to expose you to tons
of the framework elements
that we've built
into the system
so that you can hopefully build
richer user experiences.
As an aside note as well,
several of the examples
that I will demo today
were created out
of an emulator
which shows a cursor.
The cursor is meant
to indicate touch.
To set the stage for you,
so to speak,
the talk is gonna focus
on the three pillars
of interaction design
that we've
modeled the interac--
that we've modeled,
excuse me, Android around:
structure, behavior,
and expression.
We're going to talk
at a strategic level first
about what
makes Android unique.
So as you start to develop
and design applications
for the platform, you should
think about these key things
that I will highlight.
I will also then step back
and expose some of the ba--
the, excuse me, the basics that
are a part of our framework.
Then we're gonna dive
into the behavior layer.
And behavior is how we bring
structure to life in Android.
We'll cap off
with probably what will be
an interesting exploration.
That would be
we'll talk about expression.
That's generally
where you need to focus
a lot of your energy
but it often gets overlooked.
And hopefully,
if I don't talk too fast--
actually, if I talk fast,
you'll have plenty of time
for questions.
So we'll handle those as well.
Now as I mentioned,
and if anyone's seen
my trailer video,
the Android user experience
is based upon
the principles
of interaction design.
And these principles,
there's three pillars of them,
are structure, behavior,
and expression.
If any of you know
a little bit about
the history
of interaction design,
what this means
is it's grounded in--
its roots are grounded
in architecture.
So if I were to give you
an example of an architect,
which I'm going to,
we could look at how
we should start
to think
about these three pillars.
An architect,
when he or she first starts
the process
of designing a building,
well, he or she
lays down a blueprint.
And on that blueprint
are certain
predefined structural elements
that need to go into place
for that building.
For example,
there's gonna be floors.
At some point,
there's gonna be doors,
there's gonna be elevators.
There's probably gonna be things
like light switches as well.
Plumbing.
This is all
basic structural elements.
After that, the architect
will then jump
into the next pillar,
and that's the behavior pillar.
What that means is wherever
he or she has decided
to place these elements,
like doors or elevators
or light switches,
he or she as the architect
is starting to think about
how they're gonna behave
when a user enters the room.
For example,
with the light switch,
are there gonna be
motion sensors
that trigger the light
on or off?
Are there going to be--
is it just going to be
a press and hold type of thing
that turns
that light switch on?
So structure and behavior
come together
in the final pillar,
which is expression.
At this point, the architect,
probably working
with an interior designer
or someone like that,
has decided that, you know,
how that light switch behaves--
which could be a slider
or it could be
a button as I mentioned--
that kind of has to have
an expression
so that when someone
enters the room,
they know how to turn
that thing on.
So that's at a high level--
a good way to start
to think about how we think
as designers on Android
when we build applications.
Now, as I told you,
we're gonna go from
a structural level first--
or, excuse me,
a strategic level first
with the framework
and show you some of the things
which have been blogged about
quite extensively.
But since we haven't really
published our UI guidelines
just yet, you probably
could use a little refresher.
And that's why I'm here.
I'm gonna provide you
with five unique things
that you need to think about
that make--
when you start to design
and develop for Android,
that makes us different
than other platforms.
The first thing is multi-tasking
with background processing.
In the example
that I'm about to show you,
which is very fast,
pay close attention
to how in Android
I can be doing one task
but then quickly switch
and take action on data
as it enters my view.
It's really powerful.
I'll walk you through this.
So here I'm browsing
in YouTube
and I'm deciding
what I want to watch.
Well, look what happens.
Through
the notification tray
or window shade,
I get a message.
And I'm immediately able
to act on that
and go directly
to Google Talk.
Even more powerful,
my friend has sent me a link.
So I can hook--from that link,
I can go right to the browser
and I can browse and decide
whether or not
I'm interested in going
to this location
to meet up with him.
Now that was pretty--that
wasn't as fast as I expected
when I did that,
but I decided that okay,
that looks good to me.
And I can quickly respond
to that message.
Another thing to keep in mind
which is--this is going
somewhat fast,
is we have a notion
of a back stack in Android.
So each time I want to go back
to a previous activity,
which is, for example,
Gchat or YouTube,
I can hit the back button.
Now what was also
kind of important
which you probably
may have not seen
is that the data was held
in a stateful place
each time I went back.
So multi-tasking,
background processing,
first key differentiator
for us
that as a developer,
you should probably think about:
how you're going to hold
that data.
But also again,
another key point:
how to allow people
to act on data.
We'll talk more about that.
The other key thing
that was exposed in that demo
was the idea that we have
on Android which is very unique,
which is notifications.
There's two types
of notifications
in the Android framework.
There's ongoing
and event-driven.
Ongoing notifications
are very temporal.
They last a short time.
They're meant to indicate
progress.
For example, what happens
when I download an app?
Well, as a user, I can flick
down that window shade
and I can see
the progress indication
as to how long it's taking
that app to download.
Once it's downloaded,
that notification
switches into--
that's an ongoing notification.
That switches into the one-time
event notification
where I can then act on it.
One-time notifications
are things like email and SMS
that a user can quickly tap
and go to the application
that has presented them.
On Android,
what's really important
is to be a good citizen
with notifications.
Because you can surface
notifications to a user
doesn't mean you
should abuse it.
So, you know, we've seen
some bad examples,
but we're hoping that
this talk will help you
better understand how
to use the power of this.
And the reason why
I mention this
is that you want to see
good ratings and comments
in the market
when you develop an app.
You spend a lot of time
on that,
so not abusing the framework
with notifications
is probably a good way
to promote that.
Now, another new thing
with Cupcake,
if you've read the blog post,
is we are now allowing data
to come out of applications
and sit on the desktop.
We have implemented widgets
and live folders
in Cupcake 1.5.
And what this means is
as a user of an application,
I can long press
on the home screen,
and we'll see
an example of this,
and drag and drop and put
a widget on the desktop
that exposes data at a glance.
One of our reference apps
is the calendar,
which is pretty powerful
because I can see my schedule
on a daily basis.
And if I decide that I want to
actually go into the calendar,
all I have to do
is tap that widget
and I'm taken directly
into the calendar.
The other key component
of data
that we've been able
to surface on the desktop
in a dynamic way is--
excuse me, uses live folders.
And live folders allow you,
the developer,
to take a dynamic subset
of data--
for example, maybe a group
of contacts or whatnot--
and put that in a folder
and that list will automatically
update for the user.
So when he or she selects
that folder from the desktop,
it's pretty actionab--
it's always updated
and it's actionable.
Here's an example
of live folders and widgets.
Again, pressing the home screen
triggers a menu.
I decide which widget
I want.
Calendar in this case.
And then I can go
into the calendar
and I have a pretty light
schedule today.
Isn't that nice?
And I can decide what
I want to do there.
I can always hit back
and I'm back to the home screen.
So here's live folders.
These are what we ship with.
We're already seeing more
live folders get created
as application developers
like yourselves
get hold of this code.
And I can browse
my contacts list
and then quickly
go into a contact card
all from the desktop
without having
to go into the application.
So, very powerful.
Again, the theme of acting
on data from the desktop.
Now, as many of you may know,
with Android,
it's not about applications.
And let me rephrase that.
It's about activities
that you then layer tasks into,
and then on top of that,
you can hook in intents.
And intents make it possible
so that you can basically--
if there's an intent over here
that's share, for example,
but you're over here,
you can take
that intent and hook it
into your application so that
you didn't have to build that.
You're reusing it, but you're
making the user experience
much more powerful
for the user.
We're gonna look
at two examples in the camera
and the browser as to how
we utilize share intents,
or intents in general.
But we're gonna look at
the share intent specifically.
So this is
a really fast example.
I'm gonna let it play
and we'll see what happens.
Basically I'm in the camera
and I take a picture.
Afterwards I decide,
using the thumbnail viewer,
that I want to share it.
Once I hit the share button
from our onscreen action menu,
I have a choice
of menu options
with that
share intent dialogue.
We ship with some
predefined appli--you know,
default intents
for the user.
But you c--
as a third party,
this is what I think you guys
would be interested in
is any third party
can hook into that share intent.
So, you know, while I
could've sent that picture
through SM--
the messaging app,
the messaging app, rather,
PicSay was also
in my third party intent
because I had downloaded
the PicSay application
from the market.
And what that left me with
was the opportunity
to basically
cartoon up my image
before I shared it
with a friend.
So that's a pretty good example
of how we use the share intent
in the camera.
What about the browser?
Well, it's highly likely
when I'm browsing a web page
that at some point
I'm gonna want to share content
with someone.
So in this instance,
I can long press on an image
and then bring up
the contextual menu.
There I can share that link
through the share intent
dialogue.
Again, type in a message
and send it off to a friend
and then return back
to my previous activity,
which is really powerful.
So again,
intent's a good thing.
That leads us to this point
in the presentation.
Most platforms are all about
a simple linear path.
You go into and out of
applications.
As you can probably
tell by now,
when you start
to think about designing
and developing for Android,
we think more in terms
of a stream.
So this is the model
that you should probably start
to think about
instead of this model,
a straight line.
Because with the stream,
you can basically
hook in intents
and then allow the user
to pivot on data.
And that's really what
we want as a user anyway,
is to be able to quickly use
the multi-tasking techniques
and act on data
that interests us
rather than having
to stay siloed
and go into and out of things.
So here's an example
of how I can do that
in the browser again.
As I'm--you know,
quickly I was browsing
for Star Trek.
I decided that I wanted
to view that in YouTube.
I had two choices.
I could've continued
that activity
through the browser
or the YouTube client app.
I chose YouTube
because I prefer that app.
And in YouTube,
through the main menu button,
I was able to trigger
the share intent.
I triggered the main menu
and I was able
to trigger the share intent
by selecting that function.
I could share that--
I shared that video--
I can share that video
with a friend
and then I jump right back
to the browser.
So again, with Android,
it's a stream
as opposed to a linear flow.
And that's really powerful
when you start
to think about how you
can leverage that as well.
Now, I'm gonna step back
as I said previously.
Those are, like,
the high level things
that we tend to think about
and we know--
we tend to think about
as designers on Android.
But at a basic level,
Android is really about
making the software
and the hardware
come together.
So you can't have
a good user experience
if you don't do that.
And the way that
we've tried to do that--
this is
our second representation
of an Android device--
is the Vodafone HTC device
that we shipped
in Europe recently.
And how we do that--
I'm gonna walk you through
some of the things
that are associated
with that right now.
We have hard key buttons,
basically.
We have home still,
which always takes you home.
And we also have the notion
of a long press
on these buttons.
So if you long press on home--
I think several of you have
gotten this phone right now
at the keynote this morning--
if you long press on that,
you can quickly see
a task switcher will come up.
So the hard keys
aid navigation.
They're also meant to be doors
into greater functionality,
which we'll soon see
with the next button,
which is the menu button.
The menu button is the way
that you can surface
more content on the screen
by minimizing onscreen buttons,
basically.
Because we have a menu that
serves as the global function--
it serves as the place to put
those global functions, rather.
We have a track ball
for fine, focusable navigation
because this isn't
always that good
when you want
to hit a web link.
We have a back stack,
which is a technical thing.
But that back button
is really powerful
because no matter where I am
inside of an application,
I can always jump back
one step.
And as I showed you
in some of the examples,
what's important about that
is that you hold the state
that the data was in
for the user.
so it doesn't reload.
And that's really powerful.
We added a search button
to make it fast to search
and we still have
our send and end keys.
Send calls--
lets the user call.
It also takes you
to the call log.
And end will either
end the call,
or if you long press on that,
give you a fast way
to go into airplane mode,
for example.
And this is
a touch screen device,
mainly portrait, which means
we have an onscreen keyboard.
Now, previous to this,
I think many of you
hopefully purchased
this product.
It's the G1.
And what this device represents
is the classic QWERTY slider.
It also call--
the reason why I put this up
is that you have
to call attention to the fact
that you shouldn't forget
just because now
we have
this great portrait device
that landscape exists
in layouts.
We turn landscape off in the HTC
magic on the home screen,
but its not off in other views
of your application.
For example,
if I rotate in Gmail,
it will go
into landscape mode.
So as a developer,
it's important
not to overlook landscape.
In the screenshot that I'm
showing on the left-hand side
of the screen here,
Amazon did a really nice job
in considering
what to do when the device opens
in landscape view.
You can see that they
had four buttons in portrait
that looked
and fit really nicely.
They're easy to touch.
But what happens
when we open up that slider?
Well, they actually chose
to do it 2x2,
which kept everything
above fold.
The key point
I'm trying to make here
is that when we open up
to landscape,
we get a greater width
but we reduce the height.
And this
will be really important
for you to think about
when you design widgets.
Anyone who's read my widget
guidelines on the blog
from the blog post
will identify with that point.
You lose a great deal
of real estate
in landscape mode.
And another point that our
engineers wanted to make today
which I'm happy to make to you
is that 99% of our layouts
in the SDK support landscape,
so you should be okay.
Here's another example
just to drive home the point
of what happens when you
go into landscape mode.
On the left-hand side
of the screen,
we're looking
at the browser bookmarks.
Now, I can easily access
five bookmarks in portrait.
It's great, no problem.
As soon as I go to landscape,
I'm down to two.
So just a visual cue
to show you guys
what happens with landscape,
which you probably already know
but I thought I'd, you know,
just go through it
one more time.
Now, this is a really big thing
to think about
in terms of the basics
when designing for Android:
focus and menus.
Because we support both touch
and, you know,
track ball navigation,
there's really not
a notion of focus onscreen.
Let me play an example
for you to illustrate
what this means.
Here I'm browsing in touch.
In touch mode,
there is no focus.
However, when I flick
and go use the track ball,
focus appears on screen.
As a designer and developer
for Android,
just make sure
you never show focus.
There's a great blog post
about touch mode
that's been written.
I highly suggest
you take a look at that
in case you haven't
seen it already.
And then
when I hit the main menu,
there is no focus on that
until I either press
with my finger
or track ball select.
Now, I just exposed you
to the main menu
and I've kind of touched
on that in some of the examples.
I may be moving a little fast.
So hopefully
I can slow it down.
But the main menu,
in terms of structure,
it implies a great deal
of structure.
As a developer or a designer
for Android,
the way you should
think about the main menu
is that it is comprised
of global functions.
We can comfortably fit
up to six items onscreen.
However, if--six items
on the main menu.
However, if you
have more than six
we suggest
you use the more button,
which means you get five--
as you can see over here--
five plus one on the right-hand
side of the screen.
Another thing to keep in mind
with the main menu
at a high level is that it
allows you to act on that list.
So in Gmail, for example,
we have seven list items.
When I select one,
which is the fifth one,
and I want to view
that conversation,
those global functions
that were on the home screen
actually don't carry over.
There's global functions
that carry over
into the item
that you've selected
that relate
to that conversation.
So key thing to keep in mind,
implied structure with menus,
five plus two.
And also something else
about main menus
that you may not know
is that we rank order--
we order them in terms
of importance, rather,
from left to right.
So if you look across
our applications,
we generally put refresh
in either the first or second
slot across our apps.
That helps with muscle memory.
And this is something you guys
should keep in mind.
Now, if we have this global
function called the main menu,
how do we pivot and act
on contextual items?
Well, as many of you may know,
we have the notion
of long press.
So I can be browsing a list--
for example, context--
and then I can press and hold
or track ball press and hold,
and then that will trigger
a long press menu.
Now that long press menu--
which played very fast,
so we'll do that again.
That long press menu has
an implied structure as well.
At the top of that
long press menu
is the most relevant
contextual action
to the item
that you've selected.
So when you're browsing
the contact list,
normally when you
tap that person's name,
you're going to go
to the contact card.
If you long press
to get additional functions
related to that person,
you still have the first option
to go to that contact card.
So that's our structure
with long press menus.
So now we have global
and contextual menus.
And we'll also show you
an example here
of what to do
with that more menu.
As I mentioned before
when you have more than--
we can fit six comfortably.
When you have more,
we ask you put it--
the rest of those functions
that are not primary
into the more menu button.
Here, for example,
in Google Talk,
I can hit the more menu
and then I have
not that many options
but I have settings.
That's where I chose
to put settings.
And I let the user
act on that.
And they can hit
the back button at any time
to go back
to the previous screen.
Now, these are pretty good
basic concepts,
and I also wanted to give you
an example today
of what we think,
as a team, the limit is
in the list view
framework structure
for displaying data
and information.
There's a lot of density
that exists in Gmail.
And this is a view of how
you can use the structure
to your advantage.
We have a three-column layout
here that allows us
to put check boxes
on the screen,
which you'll soon see
in behavior trigger a mode.
We have
the conversation list view
which you can tap on,
or again, long press
and have
contextually related items
to that
list view button element.
And then we have
the notion of the star,
where a user
can assign importance.
Now the other thing
that's implied
in the framework structure
that you should think about--
this kind of blends
into behavior
and we're gonna get--
you can tell that
it's very interrelated
in terms of how design works.
But as a developer,
you should think about
the notion of read or unread,
so you can show a user
whether or not something
has been read
with white on black,
bold text, rather--
bold text on white.
Or if it's been read,
it's on gray
and it's regular text.
So a lot's going on
in structure.
And a couple of key points
which I talked about today
are when you're thinking about
designing and developing
for Android,
think about speed
and simplicity.
Minimize
your onscreen actions.
Use the main menu.
Also, keep your hierarchy
as flat as possible.
What I showed you in that
previous example calls out--
there's a lot
of dense information,
but I didn't have
to dig too deep
to figure out what to do
on that screen.
The other thing in some
of the examples that I noted
was the idea of a lazy load.
What we want to do on Android
for the user
is to progressively load
in data.
It gives the perception
of speed.
And it's pretty powerful stuff
when you do it like that
rather than waiting
for the whole page to load.
Because, you know,
someone might just get bored
and decide to use
the back button or back out--
get out of your application
completely.
So not a good thing.
And then the other big thing
to keep in mind
is activity streams.
Make sure
your activities and tasks
layer in or hook in intents.
They'll make the user experience
much more powerful.
And they'll give you, again,
greater flexibility.
You don't have to design
or develop everything
because you
can take advantage of it
from other parts
of the framework.
Okay, the second pillar
of the Android user experience:
behavior.
Here's how we're
going to ta--
we're actually going to bring
that structure to life.
And what does that mean?
Well, let's take a look
at an example in Gmail again.
So as I mentioned,
we had those check boxes
which you could trigger
a mode.
You know, besides
going into a conversation
and looking at that directly,
which is what we had in 1.0,
we've implemented
a new behavior
that when you
select a check box,
you can see that
up from the bottom comes a bar.
And that bar allows you
to archive, label, or delete.
That's a behavior--
an animated behavior
that signifies that
we're in a multi-tasking mode.
As a user, I can now triage
my inbox.
I still have another behavior
to talk about
in that we show Toast.
So that Toast tells you
a very quick confirmation
that, "Oh, I have in fact
deleted that."
So we layered in behaviors,
and that brought
that structure to life.
Another example of behaviors--
and actually, I downloaded
an app this morning
that I wanted to call out,
that you guys
should all download.
It's a Google I/O calendar
for Android.
It uses expandable lists.
And that allows--
it allows the developers,
much like it allowed us in
the browser history view here,
to compress
a lot of information
into one list view button
element.
And then you could expand that
depending on how much
you wanted to view at one time.
Because, you know, if you look
at the browser, for example,
there's gonna be a ton
of bookmarks in your history.
So that could go forever
and you could be scrolling
endlessly.
If you use an expandable
list behavior,
you can compress
that information
in a way that a user
could actually digest.
So here's just another
element of a behavior
that you might want to consider
when you've build a structure
with an expandable list.
This is my favorite behavior
that we have in the system,
or one of my favorites.
And that is the ability
for direct manipulation
of a list
through drag and drop.
In the music player example
that you see here,
I'm able to reorder
my playlist.
And it's really powerful.
The other thing that this
example kind of highlights again
is the notion
of expression.
The way that I know as a user,
the hint for me, is that
little icon on the left.
That was my hint
to drag and drop.
So that's a cool behavior you
can take advantage of as well
in terms of when
you're looking at a list
you structure--
excuse me,
our structure for lists.
Another point, though,
to make about behaviors
is it's not all--it's not always
gonna work out perfectly.
In the example on the right
with the browser bookmarks,
we didn't allow
for direct manipulation.
And we heard about it.
It's not a great idea.
So we plan on changing that
in the next release.
As much as we think
we know what we're doing,
sometimes we don't.
And you guys as developers
are gonna have
to try out behaviors too.
Because generally,
even though
you can pick these out
of the API demos,
they may not work for a user.
So what you should do
is implement them
and get some quick feedback
when possible.
Now, for anyone that's
used our system,
we have the notion of a Toast.
A Toast is a tool tip
in Android.
And the point I want to make
about a Toast
is that it's meant to be used
when a user actually has
their attention on the screen,
otherwise
they're gonna miss it.
We found a lot of good data
that shows
if something is going
to be harmful for the user,
it's probably better
to use a dialogue at this point.
If you use our new Gmail,
we ship with the dialogue
on for delete.
Delete confirmation on
as a dialogue in Gmail.
We don't ship with--
you can turn that off and then
you'll get Toast all day,
which is fine.
But if it's going to harm
a user, don't use the Toast
is the point
I'm trying to make.
Now, we have some--you saw
some pretty basic behaviors.
Check boxes bring things up,
you know.
It's obvious stuff.
And you can drag and drop
a list.
That's awesome,
but it's pretty expected
that once you've picked that up,
it's gonna do the--
perform the action that
you want it to take as a user.
We have the notion
of some of--
we have the notion
of delight as designers.
And in Android, you can utilize
some of the behaviors
that I talked about, especially
the long press behavior,
to create unexpected delight.
Oop, ooh, you know, I got--
I jumped ahead again.
Well, I'll get to that one.
But this one is really cool
because we have this unexpected
delight that occurs
when you use animation
that I wanted to highlight.
So here I'm gonna
shake things up, I guess.
And I'm gonna show an example
of what loop did.
They layered in behaviors.
So here is a classic
shake animation
that doesn't make me feel bad.
It's fun.
It's cute.
And I actually want to keep
making mistakes, frankly.
You know?
[laughs]
And you'll notice
that they took the time
to build behaviors so that
it enhanced the user experience.
And it actually fits their brand
pretty well.
They're fun to begin with.
And they didn't just
have to put up, hey, you know,
a red error message
and say, you know,
"Type that again."
They chose to do something
really fun.
So these are things that--
as you start
to get your head around
how to use behaviors,
that you should think about.
Now the other unexpected delight
that I was thinking
when I saw that video
was when you long press
on album art
in the browser for us,
we have this really cool ability
to surface for the user
the ability
to go to Amazon, MP3,
to either buy songs
or purchase the album directly.
You can go to the browser.
Here, I'll play that again.
You can go to the browser
to search more for that artist
or you can go to YouTube
to probably watch their videos.
And that's not expected.
In fact, I would probably say
it's a little too hidden,
but these are things that,
as a developer,
if, you know,
maybe you have a little icon
and that would indicate
a hint for the user.
And we'll get to that
in expression again--
how you can surface behaviors
better than a user
and create unexpected delight.
Okay, I'm moving
way too fast today, but...
the third pillar of expression
that I want to talk about
is probably the hardest one
to discuss in front
of a large group.
And that is that this
represents--
If you think about
structure and behavior
representing 80% of your work--
that is, you know, you've done
the heavy lifting.
The code's in place.
You've picked your behaviors.
You've hopefully
got things running.
And maybe you've gotten
some feedback.
Expression's
gonna be the next 20%
of the time you spend
building your app.
And why is that?
Because
in the expression pillar,
you're gonna have
to focus on the details.
As one of--
the best--
the best example I can give you
to focus on details
comes from a quote
from the legendary designer
Charles Eames.
Charles Eames said,
"The details are the details.
They make the product."
Now, what that means
is it's gut check time
when you get to this layer
or this pillar in the process.
Hopefully you've gotten
some feedback from people.
If you haven't, maybe you--
or maybe you've been fortunate
to actually sit
with a designer.
At that point, you have
to decide as a developer
how you're gonna
tighten up your app
to create the polish that
someone, when they open it,
is going to,
you know, think,
"Okay, this is
a really good, solid app."
And the good news is
there's a couple of things
that we built into the framework
that I can help you--
that can help you do this.
And I'm gonna go through those.
The other thing to keep
in mind, though, with expression
is that it serves a function
not just as an aesthetic.
'Cause, you know, when you
look at the new Google Talk,
you can see that the padding
and the margins are really good,
and--and it's really t--
you feel like, "Okay,
that's a very polished app."
But you also know as a user
that using the elements
of expression with a text field
and the buttons,
that I know that I can tap
that text field
and change my status message.
I can also hit the button
and change presence.
Now, there's another layer,
though, beyond the polish
that exists with this.
Can someone tell me what's
onscreen in that list view
that seems out of place
or just--
The geeky Android.
Yes, correct.
What do you think that means?
Okay, well, they're
on an Android phone, but yes.
And what that tells you
as a user, though,
is that not only--
Well, what that tells you
is it's not just a cute element.
But this person is probably,
even though she seems
to be available,
I can tell by her status message
and that icon
that she may not immediately
be able to get back to me.
So you can use expression
in a way
that gives the user
actionable information.
So as I mentioned before,
the API demos
are a really good place
to start
to build your toolkit.
We have structural elements
in there, like lists,
and expandable list.
We have behavior elements
as well.
We have dialogues.
We have spinners,
which are drop down menus.
We have Toast.
And we also have animation.
Again, there's a really good
talk today
from David Sparks about
the Android media framework
which I want to pitch
that you guys
should definitely check out
because he'll help you
with all that.
We also have something--
we also have a couple of tools
which can help you
tighten up your app.
And one of them
is the 9 patch tool.
The 9 patch tool
is really awesome.
And as a designer, let me--
I can explain it to you
as a designer
and not a developer.
But basically what that is
is it allows me
to create scalable assets.
And an asset
is a piece of artwork
that can have
a gradient or not.
But basically what happens is,
as a designer
is you create your button
element or whatnot
and you compress that
to its smallest state,
both in terms of width
and height.
And then you place it
in this tool
which you can download
from our SDK reference toolkit.
And then once
it's inside there,
you see
little black tick marks.
Now it took me months
to figure out how to use these,
so I'm no expert.
But once I did,
the power of having this tool
was awesome because basically
I could tell the developer
where I wanted him
to stretch the asset,
both vertically
and horizontally.
And then I could also add in,
as you see
on the right-hand side,
special tick marks
that indicate padding.
So in the magnified view,
the asset stretches well
vertically and horizontally,
but also the padding is uniform
all the way around.
And that's a really big thing
'cause that's gonna create
what you just saw
on the Google Talk screen,
the notion of polish
with someone who looks
at your application.
Now what accompanies a 9 patch
technique often
is something we call banding,
especially with gradients.
When you're on a 16-bit display,
it's gonna happen.
Now previous to 1.5,
the solution
to a banding element,
which--it still exists
in the browser,
and that's an example
on the left
that you really can't see--
but basically a line
will come across
when you stretch a gradient
if it hasn't been dithered.
Previous to 1.5,
the designer or developer
had to apply
a special 565 filter
in the image editing program
of your choice
to that gradient asset.
And hopefully it would dither
and it would stretch
and it wouldn't have banding.
The good news is--that's a lot
of work, by the way.
The good news is in 1.5
we've created a way
for you, with code,
that you can dither
in run time.
So that code snippet
on the right
is something that
I would probably use
if I was a developer
and I was using 9 patches.
And again, why 9 patch?
Because it compresses
the size of the image
which reduces the overall
file size of your APK.
Another really cool trick
and technique
that you should use--because
I hope everyone in this room
wants to localize their app
and not just,
you know, go international
and not just stay local--
is the marquee event,
text marquee.
You can trigger a text marquee
now in Cupcake 1.5
which will allow you
to scroll strings.
And this is really valuable
when you localize
because your strings
are going to get longer.
So an example of this
would be in the marketplace,
for example.
It is only triggered
on track ball rollover.
But then as soon as you
track ball over that
list view button element,
you can animate a string.
So you don't have to ellipsize
in the standard way
of dot dot dot, which can't
really help that many people
when you in fact go
to, like, Deutschland strings.
Another thing that
you should keep in mind
in terms of expression
is we've built in the use
of scalable pixel units
topography.
And what that means is
if you call large, medium,
or small text appearance,
this will give you the primary
and secondary string colors
and sizes that we use
in the system framework.
For example, if I look
at Spare Parts--
this is an application
that's available on the market
that many of you probably have.
I can quickly scale up or down
my font size.
But as an added bonus,
what happens
is margin and padding
stay the same.
So you basically retain
the tightness and the polish
that you want
as a developer
who's gonna distribute
an application to the world.
Now, a final tip
for expression.
Excuse me, final tip
for expression would be,
since this talk is about
"pixel perfect code,"
and if you have
the fortunate circumstance
to work with a designer
or you're a developer
that can create a mock-up
and the export a PNG file,
you'll get what we call
a pixel perfect layout.
That pixel perfect layout
can then be input
into the Hierarchy Viewer
which is available as well
for you to use.
And if you use
the onion skinning feature,
you can make sure
that all the elements
on that screen line up.
You know, you're
probably gonna customize,
so some of those tips
and tricks, while useful,
may not always be useful
because your designer
may decide that, "I need
to use a different text height
as opposed to our standard
18 SP and 14 SP."
So when that happens and--
or different elements
appear onscreen
and you want to check padding,
you use the hierarchy
of your onion skin feature.
It will help you,
it will save you time,
and it will also all you
to embrace a better focus
for the details which will make
your application better.
Now there's three talks
that will expand
on everything
I've covered here today.
There's--as I mentioned,
there's David Sparks'
introduction,
or actually, huge overview
on the Android media framework
which I would attend.
And then tomorrow
we have two developers talking:
Romain Guy,
who's gonna talk about
turbo-charging your UI,
as well as Joe Onarato,
who will talk about supporting
multiple binaries.
And Joe's talk
is really important
because he's going to explore
something we call DIP,
which is
device independent pixels.
What you saw in
the Spare Parts example
is how you will
be able to scale up
on different resolutions
and screen sizes
using that technique.
And Joe is gonna cover that,
so I would hope you would
attend that as well.
Now, I've been told
that we are going
to actually publish
a blog post today
which will be the first section
of our UI guidelines.
So you'll have more background
in what I've covered
in a rapid time
than just this presentation
to review for how to do
good Android user experience
on the web.
We've also--I also wanted
to highlight the fact
that in each SDK release,
we're giving you
the source artwork.
So you can download--
If you need a main menu icon,
you can go to the source tree
and download
the PNG file of your choice
to put into your application.
In fact, we encourage you
to do that.
And we've also been really good
and proactive lately
about publishing certain
user experience guidelines
such as icons--
for icons and widgets.
So look forward to more
of those.
Okay, and now I'm gonna take
some questions,
which we have a lot
of time for.
[applause]
Okay.
man: Hi.
What's your thought about
when the vendor
providing Android device
that does not support
touch screen?
Like, will there be
certain features that can--
can that be used
like drag and drop?
Nesladek: So the question
is what happens
when a device
is in the marketplace
that can't support drag and drop
is what you're try--
it's only track ball focus?
man: About the future devices,
hence a vendor
may create a device
that does not
support touch screen
because touch screen
is expensive component?
Nesladek: So I think--
and I'm not the one--
you should probably check out
press@google.com.
But in general, there's
a compatibility program
that exists with Android
so that generally
the people that are in the OHA,
the device manufacturers
and everyone else,
has to support both touch
and track ball focus.
So that should not happen.
man: Okay, thank you.
man: I have a question
about context menus.
I'm wondering why there
is a prohibition
against using icons
in contextual menus.
Nesladek: Well, the way
that you should think
about that menu is
it's a quick access point.
So there's no reason
to use an icon.
It's really--it's faster
to just flick a list
is how we've thought
about it.
man: Well, except that what
you may be selecting from
may not ideally
be represented as text.
For instance, if you're
doing a metronome application,
you may want to have
note values there.
You may want to have pictures
of 8th notes, 16th notes,
instead of saying, "8th note,
16th note" or whatever...
as an example.
Nesladek:
Well, I don't--I mean,
obviously
it's an open source platform,
and you can feel free
to customize it
any way you like.
What we do, though,
in terms of our UI
is to keep that
as a contextual menu only.
man: Hi.
It seems like modal dialogues
are really frowned upon
but they're just immensely
useful in some situations.
Like, for instance,
you want to insist
on logging in
before you do something,
and you may have
some screens where you offer
a different view
based on whether the viewer
is authenticated yet or not.
And most, or all other major
UI platforms
support modal dialogues.
So why is it that it's not
supported on Android,
or why is it
that it's not convenient?
And what's kind of
the official way
to do something
in a modal fashion
that really
does need to be modal?
'Cause it really simplifies
logic considerably
in some cases.
Nesladek: I don't have
a good answer for you right now.
I mean, that's--we can talk
afterwards, how's that?
man: Okay, sure.
Nesladek: Okay.
man: Hi, my question
is about the stream flow
of activities in Android.
So we could expect
that different tasks
will have different
flows of activities,
different orders,
and that when you have calls
of different activities that
are in different applications,
those are RPC calls, right?
Which need to have some kind
of synchronization and stuff.
So I was wondering
whether that
is likely to cause deadlocks,
or if there are
some suggested techniques
for avoiding
those kind of problems.
Nesladek: That sounds--
that's very technical.
I'm just a UI guy, so...
man: Oh, okay, sorry.
Nesladek: [laughs]
The Android fireside chat
will probably
be a really good place
to make sure
that you get that information.
man: Okay, sorry.
Nesladek: Office hours, yeah.
man: Hi.
I was gonna ask a question.
It seems like it's similar
to the first question,
so maybe
the answer's the same.
It was how much
can we rely on things
like the back button
being present?
Because I've seen, like,
concept phones from Germany
that have no back button.
Also go into netbooks
or some other devices.
I mean, how standard
is that hardware platform?
Nesladek: Well, if it's
a Google experience phone,
that would be like something
that we'd ship with a carrier,
you're always gonna have
a back button.
man: And will there be
non-Google experience phones?
Nesladek:
I assume there may be,
given the fact that
we are giving the software away
so we can spread
a better internet experience
on a mobile platform.
So the thing, though, is--
core to the software stack
is--core to the software
principle is the back stack.
So a back button should always
be on a device
is the way we look at it.
man: Let me sneak
one more thing in.
Is it a fair criticism
to say that long press
has kind of poor
discoverability?
I mean, there isn't
a standard icon to indicate it.
I never see any visual cues.
It took me a while to figure out
it was there.
And yet, it's so useful
once you get it.
Do you just expect that to get
into the culture over time?
Nesladek: I don't think
it's a criticism.
It's just we haven't exposed it
as much as we needed to.
So talks like this, and actually
we've been very busy,
but publishing the guidelines
will help people
start to understand
how to use that.
man: Hi.
How would you go about
developing an application
that has a lot of options
and buttons and stuff
all around your UI?
Would you store everything
in the menu or--
Nesladek:
If I can cut you off.
So you basically want
to surface onscreen actions
to the user,
is that correct?
Right, okay.
So, you as a developer
need to decide
what are the most important
actions to put onscreen.
We don't say you can't.
But we want you
to think in terms of how
you could trigger a mode
with an element onscreen
rather than having everything
up for the user.
So check--if you
look at settings,
we use check boxes
in the list view preferences.
We have that.
But main functions--
'cause the main menu
is your--basically fast track
to navigation, you should put
those functions in there.
Does that answer
your question?
man: Sure, yeah.
Nesladek: Okay.
man: Hi.
In my work,
I'm being asked to develop
a lot of custom views--
things like extending gadget
and extending list view
to have some, I guess,
vendor-specific behaviors
or special features.
I remember
in early SDK versions,
there was a tool
to, like, measure frame rate
but I can't seem
to find it anymore.
Do you guys use anything
like that?
Nesladek: Let me ask you.
Like, you want an indicator
for battery performance
and stuff like that.
Is that what
you're hinting at?
man: I remember it all being
part of the same tool.
But there was a--literally,
a paint frame rate overlay
that would, like--
Nesladek: Correct me if I'm
wrong, but it's Spare Parts.
man: Is it Spare Parts?
Nesladek: Yeah,
Spare Parts has that.
man: Great, thanks.
Nesladek: No problem.
Next question.
man: I had a question
about the back button.
And I had read somewhere
where you could actually
program the code to disable
that if you're in an app.
First of all, is that correct
and is that not recommended?
If just in case you're,
you know, you want a user
to be using an application
for a specific purpose
and you don't want them
to, like, go back
until they finish
that particular app,
because it--
that particular function?
Is that possible to do and is
that not recommended if it is?
Nesladek:
It is possible to do,
although I don't understand
why you'd want to do that
for the user
because then they can't
go back to an activity.
So it's not a wise move,
I don't think.
man: That's what I was
kind of thinking.
I had read that somewhere,
and then--
I guess another question
was on the menu.
You said y'all have
customized menus available
to where--the PNG, where you
can download, is that correct?
Nesladek:
It's in the source tree.
You should see me afterwards
'cause it's not that easy to
get to is what I've been told.
But we'll figure it out.
man: Okay.
All right, thanks.
Nesladek: No problem. Next.
man: I have a question on the--
performance-wise,
and it's actually more of a--
having different views
within single activity
versus breaking down
to multiple activities,
'cause launching different
activity always takes time.
And it happens that you click
on some line item
and it takes two, three seconds
to launch another activity,
versus if you were doing it
within a single activity
by just substituting views.
What are the guidelines
around that
of performance versus
stream flow of UI
that you recommend?
Nesladek: That's a tough--
again, that's a very--
I think you should talk
to the office hours.
Our engineers are back there.
They can probably help you
figure out, you know,
a fast principle
to help you with that.
From a UI perspective,
I don't have that knowledge
to help you do that.
man: All right, thanks.
Nesladek: Yep.
man:
I have a quick question.
I have an app
that's going to require
a lot of up front
configuration.
But having any of that
configuration
in the actual GUI would be
busy and not preferred.
How do I go about
notifying the user
the first time the--
about the complex things
they have to do to set it up
but not...
Nesladek: We have a notion
of setup wizards,
so you can step them
through each piece
of functionality.
When you first get a G1
or an HTC Magic,
you tap the android
and then we take you through
how to use that keyboard now.
So we have that and you could
help them with--surface it
with that and they just
couldn't move on
till they completed
an action onscreen
is how I would approach that.
Okay.
man: Do you have expectancy
for some drag and drop UI
developing tool?
Nesladek: Do we have--
I can't--I didn't hear that.
man: Some drag and drop
development tool
for that I can create a UI
with drag and drop button,
something like DroidDraw
but...from Google.
Nesladek: I would--
I'm not--again, designer.
But I would assume
in the API demos
that that's where
you can pick up the behavior
and then build upon that
to help you build that app
with drag and drop.
man: No.
No, I meant, like,
the visual tool to actually
create the UI.
Nesladek: Oh.
No, sorry.
man: All right.
Nesladek: Thanks.
Yeah, okay.
Oh, hey.
man: Hi, there.
Quick question.
I have an app that is gonna have
three different levels,
like three different views
for a list.
And integrating back button
with the onscreen back menus
doesn't work very well,
because, you know,
you could switch tabs
and your back
would completely get ruined.
Because you want to go back
in every single view
that you're in rather
than back between the views.
Does that make sense?
Nesladek: Let me reiterate
the question.
So I think you're building
an app that's tab-based.
Is that correct?
man: So tabs
or three different views.
Let's call it
three different views.
But three different lists
with content in them.
Nesladek:
Okay, so that's actually,
in terms of
the back stack, one--
You don't go back
between tabs.
You go back between
the activity.
So basically
the user has left with
touching that or, you know,
you can track ball press it.
But that's the only way
to go back.
man: So let me give you
an example.
So you're in the first view
on the first hand,
and you do three different
things in there.
If you're going back,
you're going back
between each of them.
But if I go to
a different view
after I've done
the three things,
I want to keep the back
functionality within that view
rather than going to the
previous view, for example.
Or the previous list,
for example.
Nesladek: We should talk after.
man: Okay.
[laughs]
Nesladek: Okay.
All right,
looks like that's it.
So thank you very much.
[applause]